this holiday season revisit the greatest
Christmas movie ever made
oh oh oh yeah you heard me it's a
Wonderful Life die hard kick off your
shoes and join the party for a movie
filled with amazing action great heroes
fantastic villains hilarious comedy
suspends romance excellent stunt work a
rich supporting cast and awesome
one-liners what you thought we were
gonna crap on die hard the guys tank top
is in the Smithsonian for crying out
loud smoothie is friggin perfect in a
decade where every action hero looks
like an unstoppable roid monster no one
kicks more ass than the guy from
moonlighting who looks like your dad
John McClane how you doing he's a New
York cop out of his element in Los
Angeles with no one to talk to but
himself whether the girls get together
have a few laughs
strap in as McClay takes on a team of
well-dressed vaguely European terrorists
played by actors who didn't speak German
but the director had them try their best
anyway she's consistent shoot the glass
led by Hans Gruber one of the greatest
movie villains of all time man which is
even cooler when it's his very first
movie well seriously way to hit the
ground running Rickman but MacLaine's
not alone mean Reginald veljohnson after
he was the cop and Ghostbusters but
before he was the cop and family matters
he was the cop in die hard he may not
have the best diet or the best judgment
I shot a kid but he's the best there is
when it comes to moral support you just
watch your ass and you'll make it out of
there you hear me he is alone tired and
he hasn't seen diddly squat from anybody
down here
I love you climb aboard for an
adrenaline-fueled thrill rush of the 80
stuff you cray like indoor smoking you
smoke carry on guns Japanese businessmen
[ __ ] work out so we got you a tape
decks cocaine pregnant drinking do you
think the baby can handle a little sip
that baby's ready to tend bar making fun
of touchscreens cute toy super cool
limousines and more cocaine Wow best
decade ever lace up for a movie full of
non-stop foot stuff make fists with your
toes fists with your toes that is either
a foot fetishes wet dream or their worst
nightmare or a different even weirder
Tarantino level foot fetishes dream
we're not here to judge so experience
the original masterpiece that inspired
countless knockoffs like die hard on a
bus die hard in a tunnel die hard on a
mountain die hard in the White House die
hard in the White House - die hard in a
mall die hard on a boat die hard on this
other boat die hard in a rink die hard
on a train die hard in a plane die hard
in another plane die hard in the
president's plane die hard in a plane
with snakes and die hard but awful -
your contract
starring Bruce Willis when he still
cared Hans Gruber waxed off Lungren carl
of duty
cocaine's a hell of a drug ATS authority
figure this man has no dick types like
your grandma and
uber black what as the limo one it's not
racist die hard in a building it's nice
to know this is what Europeans think we
sound like be sure to subscribe for more
honest trailers
yippee-kay-yay brother pucker yippie Kay
yay mr. Falcon yippee ki-yay mother
fluffer yippee-ki-yay [ __ ]
yippee-ki-yay melon farmer yippee-ki-yay
mr. Potter
yippee ki-yay mother trucker
yippee-ki-yay mother